I have to say I am super relieved to
finally get rid of godspeed and this one
talks so now we know we got the real August
heart behind bars that's not the
real godspeed once he was placed in a
meta dampening cell I questioned him as
the flash and all he could say was the
one who sent me wants infinite velocity
when you were fighting godspeed he said
we deserve your speed. who's we?
And as for mcculloch technologies i will be
resuming my position as CEO
effective immediately
it's what Joseph would have wanted
thank you
Oh Joe
How are you here well it turns out that
when the guy that's trying to kill you
kicks the bucket they lift the
protection detail
That makes sense. Nash! Hey man, yeah!
And just in time team needs you now more
than ever
well let's go save some people we love
You have been at this for hours I found
him
David's at Central City Hospital I can't
believe I just did that holy frak
iris you can control this place
Iris, stay with me
Hey ah,
you gonna clean that or what?
any day now
Come on Cinderella, scrub like you mean it
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie
it has been a day in the world of the flash
so you probably saw a whole bunch of
news this morning about some
announcements and casting changes that
they made on the fly I'll explain that
during the video there's a bunch of
Easter eggs drop storylines and things
that they're going to have to change
about season 7 because of what they did
this morning so if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos will do a new Amazon giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave all your
predictions for the flash season 7 on
the video
so obviously careful for spoilers from
everything from flash season 6 so far if
you haven't watched the season yet but
you're starting at the top working our
way down so there is some good news
number 5 the flash showrunner did
confirm that the real godspeed would be
one of the main villains of season 7 and
we all wondered what's going on with godspeed during season 6 because of all the
fake godspeed copies there were a
couple scenes in that final godspeed
season 6 episode that told us pretty
much everything we need to know about
what is going on with his storyline at
least at first the real godspeed is
implied to be creating these cyborg
speedsters sending them back into the
past through the Speed Force that used
to exist is gone now so I know
everybody's wondering about that how can
godspeed use the Speed Force
if there is no Speed Force to be used
then throughout history all these
different fake godspeeds would just
steal the speed of other speedsters is
implied that they were probably going to
other places in time but mostly we were
just focusing on what's happening with
team flash because that's what the show
is about Barry said in that final scene
that Godspeed wanted ultimate speed as
if that were somehow not the same thing
as what zoom wanted when he was stealing
speed from Barry and all the other
speedsters zoom was a velocity-9
speedster godspeed last season was also
a velocity-9 speedster they came up with
velocity 10 during the flash season 6 or
velocity X whatever you want to call it
but the way they explain it is that each
new godspeeds cyborg gets more and more
lifelike more and more powerful more
abilities this last one was able to use
special speedster abilities to leech all
of Barry's speed given the
timeline of season 7 and all the
other storylines that they have to wrap
up from the cancelled season six
episodes because of the virus it's hard
to say how many more fake godspeeds
will show up before the real one does
but number four they're basically doing
a version of godspeeds flash rebirth
arc when he went around killing other
speedsters taking their speed but they
are creating the artificial Speed Force
so that's one of the other big
storylines that they have to cover at
the beginning or at some point during
season 7 nobody wants to watch a flash
TV show where the flash doesn't have the
Speed Force and can't be the flash so at
some point at the beginning of the
season they're going to have to wrap that
up it sounded like they planned on doing
that at the end of season 6 in all those
episodes that they weren't able to do
they're going to do at the beginning of
season 7 so we don't think we have to
wait too long to figure out what's going
on with that and for Barry to get his
new artificial speed force the whole
thing with Cisco in Atlantis in the
Aquaman Easter eggs I think is going to be
wrapped up pretty quickly because he was
just going to get this one part to make
the device that will help them create
the artificial Speed Force so that's
where I think all their Aquaman's stuff
is going to take place but I don't think
Aquaman himself will appear on screen
it'll just be a bunch of Aquaman Easter
eggs so whoever shows up it's going to be a
different actor probably BD Wong has
been doing the voice of the character too
the whole time though it would be a real
badass
if they could get the real BD Wong to
show up and play August heart on screen
but I don't know if they're going to be
able to get him so we might wind up with
a different actor they didn't really
clarify if the Godspeed arc would be the
first half of the season 7 or the second
half but they still have all that mere
master stuff to wrap up at the beginning
of season 7 so she'll probably be the
villain for the first part of the season
then they'll move on to Godspeed or that
new version of reverse-flash that they
tease like the Red Death version of
reverse-flash but number three all that
mirror master stuff was supposed to be
done at the end of season six before
they had to cancel those episodes now
they're just doing the story from what
would have been episode 20 21 and 22 for
the first few episodes of season 7 they
might have to change a couple things
because of the big you know
quote-unquote news this morning and then
getting rid of one of the actors but
they won't have to change that much
stuff so we'll see how long mirror
master sticks around at the beginning of
season 7 if they were going to put her on
ice by the end of season 6 probably not
that long they also implied that they
brisk you pretty much all the people
that are still stuck in the mirror
demand
in the first two episodes that's iris
Cisco's girlfriend Camilla and
Commissioner Singh iris
still has those weird matrix like mirror
dimension powers so this'll probably
have something to do with defeating Mir
master otherwise what's the point in
giving her special matrix abilities in
there but number two all the other
storylines from the cancelled episodes
there's still a lot of stuff to have to
wrap up
there's the reverse-flash stuff that
I've talked about before they were going to
use a big reverse flash twist as their
season 7 teaser they were going to  end on a
cliffhanger involving him the video I
attached to the beginning of this is
still funny but it's obviously not their
original plan reverse flash cleaning man
hard at work I've already done a few
videos about how I think they've been
setting up a Red Death fusion style
speedster throughout the season six
episodes the entire season that's why
they went all Dragon Ball Gogeta with
Grodd and Barry that's why they made
such a big deal about reverse-flash
entering other people's bodies and
taking over with his negative Speed
Force energy red death is just a fusion
speedster but he's Batman and Barry
Allen in the comics they can't do Batman
on the show so if they do him it'll be a
different version of the character
involving reverse flash but hopefully
they'll pay that off and that also might
have something to do with Barry's new
artificial Speed Force because that's
such a big deal it seemed like they were
going to wait til the end of the season and
the finale to wrap that storyline up to
some giant disaster happens that pushes
them into season 7 then they deal with
it during the first couple of episodes
but obviously the other biggest
storyline that I haven't mentioned yet
for important reason is the sue did nice
stuff this gets into the elongated man
announcement you probably heard about
this morning so number one probably
the biggest entertainment news of the
day the flash TV show straight up fired
elongated man the actor who plays him is
totally gone they said he's not coming
back during season 7 apparently he made
some epic ly bad tweets several years
ago and just didn't delete them he
didn't clean up his timeline or anything
so I'm not going to put the tweets in my
video here because some of them are
next-level bad it's not too dissimilar
to James Gunn's bad tweets a couple
years ago getting him in really big
trouble the actor has already apologized
for trying to be an edgelord Grant
Gustin in the flash showrunner have
already made official statements I'm not
going to read through the entire statements
here but you get the basic idea the like
okay this is clearly a bad situation and
because of what's going on right now
we can't let
Stand so we're going to have to let him go
apparently Grant Gustin had no idea what
was going on none of the other flash
actors did or the producers so I have no
idea how people found out about these
crazy old bad tweets who was going
through his timeline from years and years ago
it sucks that
it happened but there's not really
anything to be done about it the show
has a thousand other comic-book
characters they can introduce so
hopefully they'll replace him with
someone cool they had just made the
actress who plays sue dibney a series
regular for season 7 I don't think
that's going to change I think she'll stay
on the show they were going to do a big
romance arc with the two of them and get
them together by the end of the season
just like they are in the comics but I
think we can say that's probably not
going to happen now but if you have any big
questions about what's going on with the
season they will start filming again
pretty soon for the most part all the CW
DC TV shows won't premiere till January
next year
congratulations gloated one you're the
giveaway winner from my last big DC
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your contact
details every one click here for my new
video on the Batman movie in that big
Joker announcement and click here for my
new Justice Society Green Lantern in the
flash video from star girl thank you so
much for watching everyone stay safe
see you guys tonight!